There's a reddit post that's circulating and it hit close to home because of what I recommended
I'm curious who's seen this reddit post that I'm talking about. It's related to the speedrun
Is Grunfeld really garbage at intermediate level? Hikaru and Levi said so
I'm mid 1500s in rapid and against e4 I've been thinking about switching to the Grunfeld
I pulled up the Hikaru and Levi tier list for intermediate levels and they placed Grunfeld on the garbage tier.
I don't get it. If your opponent doesn't know what they're doing
You can just destroy white center right out of the opening then afterwards
There's a clear plan where you march your queenside pawns down the board and enjoy a nice comfy two versus one
Opening pressure in an obvious plan for intermediate players. That sounds like the dream. Please. What am I missing?
So, of course the Grunfeld is my official speedrun recommendation
so I have not seen Hikaru and Levi's tier list, but I feel very strongly that
the biggest misconception that a lot of players have is that you somehow are supposed to not study theory as
an intermediate player
Let's say 1300 or so that somehow the expectation is that you don't need to study theory yet
and you should choose an opening where you can
You know circumvent the need to know a lot of theory and as I've been saying really from the start
I think this is one of the biggest
Misconceptions that stops a lot of players from improving quickly. Not only do I think that and I've become more radical
On this front to the point where now I basically think that
Once you reach once you cross the beginner level. I'm not saying that as a 300 you should be learning chess of all courses
Although you should by the way have a solid repertoire, but once you hit the intermediate level, let's say 1200
chess.com rapid and above
You should absolutely dedicate the whatever time you have
to
Learning theory and not only having a clear repertoire and a clear understanding of what you play, but actually memorizing
You know a good amount of theory and memorizing the main lines
As well as the openings and the variations that your opponents tend to play against you
So I really feel like people miss how much
Knowing your openings as an intermediate player gives you that boost and gives you
Super comfortable positions almost every game. It changes your experience
I think a lot of players frustrations come from the idea that because an opening has a lot of theory
That somehow an intermediate level player can't learn it, which I think is just bs. I don't think that has any
It does not correspond to the truth at all
And nobody likes to hear this because studying openings is a drag
But hopefully the speedrun is helping you
Build up your opening repertoire and now not saying it's it's impossible to succeed without learning openings
Or that there's like a quote-unquote correct way to do it. This is merely
My experience of helping people improve improve
And that's all there is to it
Okay, we're black against pavlov am from belarus
1865 definitely a good player
Hopefully, we don't get aborted
Nope, very good. Okay. So we're finally I feel like it's been ages since we've had a black game
Hopefully it will finally be able to get a mainline accelerated dragon
Now we have faced the rossolimo a couple times and now we're facing the open sicilian
Which is music to my ears. I think this is only our second
accelerated dragon
of the entire speedrun
In the first one
We faced the marozzi bind which is the move c4
and in that game, I demonstrated a
Sideline system that I find to be very effective at the intermediate level where you basically play knight f6
Before fionn kettering the bishop, but i'll review that after the game right now
We're facing knight c3, which is of course the other main line
So here we don't have the space to play the knight c3
we don't have the space for any shenanigans
We start by developing our bishop
Putting immediate pressure on the knight and white develops their bishop to e3
Which is the continuation of the main line a lot of players a lot of newer players
They tend to take on c6 in this position, which is an immediate big concession
And it's a big concession because it allows black to capture toward the center
The b file can be used by black's rook to pressure the b2 pawn, particularly if white castle's queen side
And it's much easier to prepare the central break d7 d5
so bishop e3 is a no-brainer at the higher levels and now there is an important moment because
If you're a mainline dragon player, then you can go d6 here
but the drawback of d6 from an accelerated dragon standpoint is that it allows white to transition into
A mainline dragon with the move f3
So the way to keep this uniquely
Accelerated dragon style is to first develop the knight to f6
You actually do not push any of your center pawns until later in the game
potentially even until
Four or five moves from now
And our opponent finally settles into a bit of a think
So the main move here is bishop f1 to c4
This is the most ambitious developing move queen d2
uh is
Not a main line. It's a sideline
And as far as I know, it's not a particularly good sideline either
So let's think about this move for a second queen d2
generally in all dragon setups
Anytime the queen is moved from d1
You should immediately be considering the move knight to g4 because if you can trade your knight for white's dark squared bishop
Then your dragon dark squared bishop operates uncontested, which is
Virtually always a good thing. That's an advantage for you. So if you can root out
If you can root out
The dark squared bishop you almost instantly get a good position, but it's not always that simple because after knight g4
White cannot move the bishop because then he loses the knight on d4 which is attacked twice
What white can do after knight g4 is take on c6, which as we've already discussed is generally a concession
but after we recapture white can shift the dark squared bishop over to d4
And while giving away your knight for the bishop is good trading dark squared bishops in dragon setups
Isn't always that great. That's a lot more double-edged than giving away
Your knight for the bishop. So in that resulting position, we have to come up with a response
And I have a really interesting idea. I already have to settle into a bit of a think here. So
There's some interesting tactics that occur after bishop d4 there
Yeah, of course in that position. First of all after knight takes c6 we can play dc
And engineer a queen trade, but that seems like a pretty boring option which leads to a largely symmetrical endgame that seems
pretty anticlimactic
We also have the possibility of striking at the center with the move d5
So i'm actually struggling and this is definitely something to look up after the game
I'm struggling to figure out a satisfactory response after knight g4 knight takes c6 bc and bishop d4
Because if you play e5 in that position the bishop slides one square further to c5
And as a result, we're not able to castle and we're not able to kick the bishop away with d6
Because that square will be defended twice by the queen and by the bishop
By the queen and by the bishop
So let's think about this for a couple more moments. Give me 30 seconds in silence
Definitely something I should know
But something I i've never checked. Queen d2 here has never been played against me. You know what I think we should do
What I think we should do is not overreact or do anything crazy. I think we should just castle
I think when in doubt you should just continue your development
I'm, not sure how to assess knight g4 and as we've discussed you do not want to play d6
Because that enables white to transition into the dragon with f3
Now why what is the rationale behind keeping your pawn on d7?
Well, the idea is that if white insists on playing a mainline dragon setup
Then you will be able to play d5 in one fell swoop and that is often
You know without any question a good thing for black now
White has done what I thought he would do. He's castled queenside
And there's a good reason that you need to play f3 in the mainline dragon and that is indeed to avoid knight g4
How has the situation changed as a result of white's last move?
Well, one thing i'm noticing is that the king and the queen are now aligned
What does that entail? Well, we need to recalculate knight g4 because just because a move doesn't work in one position
Doesn't mean it doesn't work in another. So what happens if we play knight g4 here?
Well, the bishop still can't move. So if white takes on c6
And then plays bishop d4 we have something very exciting in that resulting position
We have the bishop pin. We have bishop to h6 pinning the queen and the king
Now that doesn't win the queen because white can block that pin with the move f4 f2 f4
But if we keep calculating, I think black has a winning move after f4
Very good. So after f4 who can spot black's ensuing crusher?
It literally ends the game after f4 e5. Very good pawnee 7 to e5
Hitting the pawn on f4 and threatening bishop takes f4, but also attacking the bishop on d4. It's a double attack
It's a simple double attack and white loses at least a piece
So the coast is clear we can go knight g4
And we spent a lot of time on these questions. I'm not going to go into too much detail
And we spent a lot of time on these couple moves. So we'll have to speed up a little bit
Now after knight c6 bc
bishop d4
Bishop h6 white's relative relatively speaking best move is to drop the bishop back to e3
But then we get sort of an ideal scenario we take with the knight
We ruin white's pawn structure. That is like a dream scenario for us
The other thing that our opponent can do is move the bishop along this diagonal
But as i've mentioned at the start when white castles queenside and the b file is open like this it often spells
almost immediate doom
For white because we get such an easy attack down the b file
For instance, if he plays bishop f4, we can't go rook b8 because that square is controlled
But what we can do is deploy our queen to b6
That's another positive benefit of putting the knight on g4. It actually attacks the f2 pawn, which is a really easy thing to miss
So queen b6 seems like a great move to consider
But it's far from the only possible way to develop our attack
We also could very well consider the move e5 trying to chase the bishop away from that diagonal
And also enabling us to play rook b8 and we could even play the move queen d8 to a5
Which is a more typical attacking move in the dragon setup
When the b file is closed
But bishop d4 is such a natural move and he plays it and here we go bishop g7 to h6 will respond instantly
Let's see if our opponent smells a rat. He doesn't he goes f4. He walks right into the losing line
So again, this is the position we were talking about if you're you know watching on youtube and you had a hard time visualizing
The line we were talking about earlier. This is the exact position in which I asked everybody to find the move
So again, the queen is pinned and this is a natural move e5 should occur to you pretty much automatically
Because you should notice that the f4 pawn
Has to be attacked and the best way to attack something is with another pawn
And this is the power of the pin the fact that the pawn simply cannot move. It's as if the pawn on f4 doesn't exist
and
Okay, the game is not totally over white
can cut his losses
Well, not really, but the best way to cut the losses is to play bishop takes e5
And after knight takes e5 to not recapture the knight
But that's an incredibly depressing outcome
We're up a full piece and we'll still have to demonstrate a good deal of technique the knight on e5 and the resulting position
is not that easy to
Evacuate to safety because its only escape square is back through g4
And potentially white could cover that square with h3
so we'll have to finesse that a little bit to make sure that all our pieces reach home base safely, but
that's a secondary problem clearly black is winning and
Some people would just resign here bishop. We need to okay that doesn't help
That doesn't help but we need to be very careful and we need to avoid a very tempting but wrong move
So the tempting thing to do here is to say well
Before taking the bishop we might as well snag the pawn on f4 with check
But you actually have to calculate that right? There's a lot going on here
You can't just make a move based on general considerations
And if you look at that carefully after king b1, it turns out that bishop takes f4 is a grave mistake
Because if we take on d4
Then white will take the knight and then if we take white's knight
The that bishop that we put on f4 is now hanging
So we should keep the bishop on h6 and take on d4 immediately
Now if queen takes knight, then we take white's knight and we're chilling
We absolutely do not need this f4 pawn unless of course
White takes on d4
In that case, we will take on f4 with check not a single one of those arrows has been drawn correctly, but you get the point
Yeah, queen queen e2 merely hastens white's defeat. Yeah, this is going to be a total disaster
Because this pawn on c3 is such a destructive force
It's essentially used as a battering ram
Forcibly shattering white's protective cover on the queen side
So our ensuing attack is going to be decisive within five moves. I think if we play our cards, right?
Because if white plays b3
Which I think is most people's natural reaction to a pawn like this
Well, that doesn't help because we have the lobster pincer mate
If we can get our queen to a3
And we can get our queen to a3 either via e7 or via a5 either move works and that
Basically ends the game immediately the king I guess could run into the center
But remember that white is down a piece to begin with so there's not much to talk about here
If white plays bc then white's queen side is completely shattered
And we could attack that c3 pawn with a move like queen d8 to f6
Simultaneously hitting f4 as well
Or queen a5 which I would assume is the more natural move
If white does not respond
Which is in fact what our opponent has done here. I would not recommend
Hastily taking on b2. This is an important attacking point
Now again, when you're up a piece, you can basically do whatever the heck you want
But if we want to play clinically you this pawn is a great asset
We want white to be the one to play bc because after cb black white can use that pawn as an umbrella
I call it the sort of umbrella defensive method
You've probably seen it before and essentially tuck the king under the pawn
Where it'll be much much harder for us to get to the king
Which is using our own pawn as a protective cover
And that's the most effective protective cover because you cannot capture your own pawn
So what is the best way to force white to take on c3?
Or to play b3 we want to get white essentially to decide
How he wants to play on the queen side so that we could in turn properly arrange our attacking forces
Well, we could play rook b8
But I think leading with the queen is an even better idea because we know that the queen is the piece
In this case that can deliver the checkmate if white plays b3
So my preferred move is queen to b6
We are threatening maiden one
But there's a secondary threat which can be very easy to miss and that is queen to e3 check when you're attacking
You have to pay attention to both sides of the board
Right and Hess points this out a lot
Very often players kind of subconsciously section off the board
And only look at moves on the side of the board where they're attacking
But you always have to keep the entire board in your kind of mind's eye
Okay, so let's try to find the fastest path to checkmate here if we play the move queen to b4
Then the bad news for us is that that is not immediate mate because white can move the d rook away
And then if we deliver a check on a3 the king is able to play a check on a3
If we deliver a check on a3 the king is able to run away through the center
Now it's not going to run away for long
We could then for example take the pawn on a2
Or we could even play the move d5 and open up the other bishop a discovery on white's queen
But let's see if there's an if there's a more efficient way for us to checkmate
So we could throw in the check on e3
Force the king back toward b1
And then drop the queen back to c5. How about that?
well
Frustratingly white still isn't made it there white can play king a1
Queen a3 and rook d1 to b1 which is a classic way of defending against the lobster pincer mate mating motif
So in that resulting position after rook b1
It actually might be even harder to checkmate the white king than it would be if the king were to hide in the center
so
Let's think about this for a second
Maybe there's a middle ground that we could adopt here
I have an interesting idea
of course, all of this is completely winning and you know, it this is all very hypothetical because
We're up a piece and we could always just resort to
The simple strategy of taking all of our opponent like queen e3 and queen takes f4 even that would be winning
But why prolong the game when we could go straight for checkmate?
So I think
Know what we should do here
Hmm
It's interesting because it's so winning but i'm trying to be
Surgically precise here and it's not that simple actually. Okay
Here's what we're gonna do
We are going to start
With the move queen to c5
We're gonna start with the flexible move queen to c5
Yeah, we could also play a5 a4 and open up the a file
We could also play a5 a4 and open up the a file. This is hard. It's hard to be ultra precise
In a completely winning position because there's so many appetizing options rook f1. Okay now
What we're gonna do and by the way, we could still give that check on e3
But I guess then queen c5 white can just repeat moves
My idea here was to delay the check on a3 because the king wants to go here anyway
So that would kind of be a waste of a move
Instead if we're anticipating the white king running toward the center
Well, logically the best thing to do would be to open up the center
Right if we can open up the center, let's say open up the d file
Then the king will not find any measure of relief
On d1. So I think it's a perfect opportunity for us to play d5
And an instructive moment because a lot of players would kind of automatically deliver this check
You can deliver this check anytime you want. So what's the purpose of delivering it now, especially when
The king is particularly vulnerable on the square and the f pawn is still pinned
Just kind of valuable. Otherwise, white could have met this move with f5
All right now
Well, let's continue the opening up at the center. We don't have to move our bishop
Again, don't play automatically
When you're this close to checkmate, you can just play d takes e4
Because we're not afraid of queen takes h6. White has no other attackers on the king side
So in that case, we just play e takes d3 and the game is over
Or we could play queen a3 check and bishop g4 check
We could look for a forced mate there as well
But we don't need to
Bishop c4
Okay now
Note that our rooks are still disconnected. So rook to d8 here would be a blunder
The queen is aimed at that square always keep that in mind
Right when your rooks are not connected. You should be
Ultra careful about moving your rooks in general
There is a really cool idea that we could play here. It's a pretty sexy sequence
Let me just calculate it for a second before I talk about how I found it
Now the position is completely winning everything wins here
From the simple bishop to g7 to a check on a3
And i'm sure there's some mating sequence there, but I actually think I see a forced mate
And it's a really really nice concept. So
Thinking logically, right? Let's work backwards to figure this move out
Queen a3 would be checkmate if the white king did not have access to the d file to the d1 square
So it would be very very nice if we could play rook to d8
And if we could play rook to d8
Then queen a3 would be an unstoppable threat white would have simply no way to prevent the black queen from reaching a1
So well, what's stopping us from playing rook to d8?
It's the fact that the rooks are disconnected which means that moving the bishop out makes a lot of sense
But we don't just want to move it out anywhere because that gives white a tempo
We would like to make a move that forces white to react to it and then play rook d8
And as many of you are noticing
The best way to do that is bishop to g4
Yeah
And as a matter of fact
What's kind of cool about this move?
Is that if white takes the bishop?
We could play rook a d8
We could even play queen a3 check and i'm calculating a forced mate in that line. I think there's a forced mate in that line as well
King d8 uh king d1 rook d8 check
King e1 queen c1 check but why bother why bother?
especially when
this move is
You know waiting for us on a golden platter
Doesn't matter which rook by the way absolutely does not matter but i'm keeping this rook on f8
So that bishop takes f7 is less of a headache. Not that it would be a headache there either
Well rook d8 queen takes d8 was check that's the problem
If we had played rook d8 first queen takes rook would have been a check
White's only way to stave off checkmate is bishop d3
But in that position we could end the game
Probably even rook takes d3 is forced mate
Man, I mean everything wins there, but we have kind of a nice mating sequence if we really want to be fancy
Now obviously king b1 queen a3
Is unstoppable main and that is a pattern that everybody should be familiar with
I know he car refers to it as lobster pincer mate. That's kind of caught on
And the kind of tactics that revolve around the lobster pincer mate are are really important to understand
and
Just to point out that pincer mate is not a good move
and um, just to point out that bishop d3 here the fastest mate is in fact rook takes d3
pawn takes d3
queen e3 check
Again, you can spot the
mating patterns here king b1
And you don't even need to take the pawn just go queen d2 and again, it's the lobster pincer mate on b2
That's totally unstoppable white gets stave it off
But you just take the rook
So even faster is c2 check. This is made in two
It's actually made in two
Yeah, this is made in two or king b2 c1 equals queen mate discovery the queens defend each other
So a very easy game it was unfortunate that our opponent blundered this quickly
But still more successful experiences with the excited dragon
And again, we're we're seeing that it's the sicilian that nobody studies at this level
And when you're on your own in a sicilian bad things tend to happen to you
Okay, so let's have a quick look
Um, and again, you know that I can't we don't have a guarantee that all the games are going to be equally interesting
But hopefully the the post-game analysis makes them worth it
Okay, just a moment
so
This is the first time that we have faced knight to c3
Previously we faced the marozzi bind, which is what most grandmasters play against the accelerated
And you might remember that my recommendation here is not bishop g7
But instead to start with knight f6 already setting a trap
If white tries to punish you by taking and going e5 you have a fork on the king in the pawn
So of course knight c3 is
Standard then you trade and play d6 you do things in a slightly weird move order in order to lure the queen
Onto a vulnerable square why is it vulnerable because when you fianchetto the bishop you're you're often going to gain a tempo
Because the queen is going to have to move out of the potential discovery
If I remember correctly our first game in the open sicilian went something like our opponent went here
And I think in this position our opponent went bishop to e3
Which is a big positional mistake who can remind me why it's a big positional mistake. And this is also on theme
It's not that we have a win. We can't win the queen here
But we go knight g4
This is kind of a no-brainer if you're an accelerated player because again trading the knight for the bishop is almost always a good thing
We have uncontested control
Of key dark squares in the center. I think we played bishop e6 here and we kind of won a nice positional game
So you could refresh your memory. That game is on youtube as well
Here in this position after castles white's main move is i'm pretty sure to move the queen back queen d3
Queen d3 and then to develop the bishop and white is slightly better if he handles this very precisely
But it's still a very playable position where it's pretty easy to learn a lot of the ideas
Anyways, this is beside the point. We're facing knight c3 bishop e3
And after knight f6 the move queen d2, which I
Honestly, yeah have never come across and i'm looking at the engine and seeing that castles is indeed the correct move
So we made the correct decision here
Now why am I avoiding recommending the mainline dragon?
Well, the mainline dragon and the accelerated dragon are two completely different animals. Well, they're the same animal. They're the dragon
But in terms of the positions that they produce they could not be more different
Essentially, the only similarity is that you fianchetto the bishop in when I say mainline dragon
Some people might not know what I mean
So what I mean is the sort of traditional dragon where you play d6 d4
And this is the entry point to the night or which is a6 which I could have recommended
And the dragon is g6
It's not that it's been refuted. It hasn't been refuted, but it's a ridiculously risky opening and you have to know
Loads and loads of theory and you have to know what's going to happen
Loads and loads of theory and you could still get checkmated even if you know loads and loads of theory also
It's theoretical standing right now is pretty dubious
And there have been a lot of analysis done
in the main lines, so
I think players are more likely to study the dragon from white's perspective than the excited dragon
And the key distinction is that in the mainline dragon white plays f3
And the main line goes knight c6 queen d2 castles and you normally get opposite side castling
This is one main line. And then the other main line white first develops the bishop to c4 to stop d5
I think this is called the yugoslav attack
But in this line where black plays d5
This might be familiar to some people who are watching
This is the main line the most popular line nowadays white plays bishop to d4
There's that idea again where white tries to take black's fianchettoed bishop out of commission
And often black is forced to make this very undesirable move e5
Closing down the diagonal for the bishop and this takes a lot of the fun out of the dragon
This line that you see right here is incredibly popular among white players
And white is considered to be better in in this line. That's not really subject to debate
And black often sacrifices this exchange by the way, although anish giri
In his chessville course recommends the relatively rare move rook e8, but that's beside the point
As we go back to the accelerated dragon the thing that's most important to understand
And this is a trap which even bobby fischer fell into white could essentially try to get the same type of position
And play the move f3. I think a lot of players do make this move at a lower level and after castles
White plays the move queen d2. What is the difference?
Well, the difference is that we have not committed to the move d6
So we can save a tempo on that move and play d5 in one fell swoop
This exact position would occur in the main line dragon, but it would be white to move in this position
And white would take on d5
With black to move there are no problems at all. You can play knight takes knight
and after
Well after queen takes knight you have a simple discovery knight takes d4 and black is much better
And if bishop takes knight then you take the pawn on e4
And clearly black's position is very very comfortable here
I think something like queen a5 yields a great position white structure is damaged
Our pieces are coming out nicely and this is really doesn't even compare to that other position
I could check the engine here, but we'll save that for another day
Okay, so that's the point right you're saving a tempo on d6
Now the way that white could try to punish you
Is by saying okay, you don't want to go d6
I'm going to take on c6 and play e5 myself and punish you for not playing d6
But I I showed this line I think in the previous accelerated video and the point is you actually go back to g8
All right. This is a move. You simply have to know otherwise
It might be hard to get yourself to play this move
And after f4 you redeploy the knight through the other side of the board you play knight h6
And oftentimes the knight reaches f5 pretty quickly
And because black has such a healthy structure
The you know relatively many moves that you play with the same piece that simply cannot be punished
White can play queen d2. I mean the theory goes on here and after black castles and white castles
you can
Disrupt this pawn on e5 by playing even the move d6 here is very very strong
And if white plays too materialistically takes takes takes then black is going to develop
Uh, not just an initiative but black wins the exchange in this position
With what sequence of moves who can spot the two moves which win material for black?
Yeah knight f5
Forces the rook back and the bishop comes out to a6 and tosses the rook out of d3. So
This is a good application of the knight going from f6 g8 to h6 eventually to f5
So in any case these this is stuff that we will i'm sure get to in more depth
But in this game, we faced a different kind of mistake the move queen d2 and here I think I responded very well. So let me
Reiterate the logic behind not playing knight g4 here, and that's a valuable thing to remember
so the reason we don't play knight g4 is because of knight takes c6
and
Yes, I said that this structural transformation typically favors black
But the extenuating circumstance here is this very annoying move bishop d4
And it's annoying because we don't just want to give away our bishop for white's bishop
This type of position is better for white and that should be pretty obvious to you, especially if you have to castle
White could just knock the knight away with f3 gain a tempo
And this type of position looks very unappetizing
Because the bishop is an integral part of our ability to attack the white king once it castles queenside
Now we have several ways to avoid that and I was considering the move e5 but now after bishop c5
We were just paralyzed. We're paralyzed. We can't castle because it's illegal white controls the f8 square
We would just die to play the move d6, but we can't do it. I mean, it just blunders the pot
We can't really play d5 because that's defended three times
And we can throw in a move like bishop h6
but what does that really do white drops the queen back and our pieces are stuck in no man's land and the knight is hanging and
I don't see a way for us to make this work
So these are the kinds of subtle
Points that you find out when you play an opening a lot
Right. And so when you just start playing an opening you're going to make a lot of mistakes
They're going to face moves that you don't know
So you need to be patient with yourself. That is why I decided to castle and I think that was the correct decision
So here once again if white castles
Then we reach the game continuation and now we play knight g4. That's what happened in the game
I don't think white has any good moves in this position
If white plays f3
We just talked about this black plays d5 and we transpose
Into the line that we just analyzed
and
By the way, if white plays well, what else can I do in this position?
I guess white can take on d5, but then we take on d5
And in the event of the mass trade look at how our pawn very nicely reaches c6 and supports the knight
You should completely ignore this damaged pawn structure much more important
Is how active our pieces are and if white tries to play bishop d4 here
Then because white isn't castled yet
This reaches a completely different position to the instance where white plays bishop d4 here
These are two completely different positions here. We're castled white is uncastled white's played this weakening move f3
A lot of things are different. The engine recommends e5
And after bishop c5
And after bishop c5, there's some really cool engine recommendations that even gives rook to b8 as a possibility
Sacrificing the exchange and one trap that i've seen a lot of people fall into
This trap exists in other lines of the dragon you take back with the queen
And if white castles, oh, let's defend the pawn
Bishop h6 again never forget about this move, especially when white lacks a dark sword bishop and you win the queen
And notice how your queen supports that
Bishop on h6 very easy to forget about
If you don't know this idea beforehand
So that's one possibility, but you can also play the simple move knight takes c3
and
Well if white recaptures with the queen
Who can tell me the strongest move for black? Let's see who has understood the spirit of the accelerated dragon
Yeah, you just play e4 right anytime you can open up your bishop like this with tempo
You absolutely should you're also opening up the center white is totally busted and in a position like this
You should never hesitate to sacrifice the exchange just take on f3
And after bishop takes f8, even if you play this very primitively and recapture
I see the engine is giving like bishop takes because they're they're tactical moves
but even if you just take you should understand that this position is
Indefensible for white because just look at the king's placement in the center again
White can't castle because of bishop h6 that's important
And if white recaptures, well, for example, you can deliver a check
You could snap off the pawn on b2 queen e8 is never dangerous because you could cover with the bishop
That's the beauty of the fianchetto
And otherwise white's position just totally and completely falls apart rook c1
Which is bishop d7 and rook e8 bring the last reserves into the game and you can analyze this more on your own
But your intuition should be pointing in the right direction here. You should understand that this is
just totally overwhelming for black if white plays bishop takes rook here again, you play queen takes f8
And it's the same drill queen takes c3 e4 is crushing white could keep eating
but you're gonna keep checking queen before check c3 queen takes b2 and
Obviously this runs into just checkmate in two moves easy to calculate these lines
And if white plays pawn takes c3
Then this is very valuable for us because white can essentially never castle queen side
The king is now stuck in the center, but I would still play the move bishop h6 here
Not necessarily to keep the king in the center just to bring the bishop to a more active square
And now a move like queen c5 looks really good tying white down to c3
The bishop comes out and here white can already resign just because white's position is completely in shambles
queen c4 queen e3
And this is why I love you know, Sicilians because they teach you how to attack and you're gonna get these types of positions a lot
If you're like under 2200
So in any case just a couple of lines to stimulate your creative juices
um
What lessons can we derive from this analysis?
Well, first of all, you should be very cautious of this situation where the bishops are staring at each other
And you should not be giving away your dark sword bishop for white's bishop unless
You know, you have to or there's some extenuating circumstance. So you would rather play e5 and
Temporarily close the bishop down than trade on d4
Don't be afraid to sacrifice the exchange on f8 in most circumstances
Even if you let white castle queen side that sacrifice is still warranted
And the other thing is just the sort of basic philosophy behind the accelerated is that you're trying to save a tempo
On the move d6, which you don't play until like five moves deep into the main line
so
Anyways, f3 we play d5
As we've already discussed knight takes e6 bc and e5 here makes no sense because here you actually just have knight g4
And this is just a disaster for white
and
Our opponent's move now is the time for knight g4 just concrete thinking
Allows us to understand that in this position. We have this additional resource bishop h6
which now hopefully nobody who watches the speedrun game will ever forget about looking for bishop h6 in
Dragon positions and in general in a lot of sicilians
This bishop h6 idea is so easily missable by a lot of players for some reason
I've noticed that players miss a lot of tactics on this specific diagonal
Which involves a queen on d2 and a newly castled king and a bishop appearing on this diagonal because I think in players' minds
They tend to sort of assume that a fiancetto bishop can't move from its fiancetto square
Bishop h6 is a natural. I have an example of this from an old game that I played. I just remembered this
So take a look at this game
And in this game, I played the knight or if and I played a terrible line
But I had analyzed it beforehand and it relies on a trap, which my opponent fell into
This is a game from 2005
I was a night or if player back then and I was a night or flare until I was a gm
So my opponent played bishop b3. This is called the english attack of the night or if I played night g4
Which is a move that is still played. It's it was very popular in the early 2000s
I mean kasparov was playing it grishuk a lot of night or play and vl was a big night g4 guy nowadays
e5 which I play myself is more popular
But anyways, this is beside the point
So we followed the main line and here the main move is I believe bishop to g7
But I had analyzed the move h5
With the obvious threat of h4 my opponent sees it. He goes h3
Forcing the knight back. This line is garbage. It's like plus minus but here's the rub queen d2
Now bishop to h6 in one fell swoop
And my opponent very confidently castles queenside
Now he does not miss the move g4
He saw the move g4 in and of itself because
White can block that with bishop f4 right the same motif
But what did he miss and here by the way black actually can also win the piece
But it's a much inferior version here than it is to switch up the move order
What's the move that my opponent missed?
Yeah, so you start with e5
And the point is that once the knight moves you're able to play g4 and win the queen
He tries knight f3 which is resilient g4 and knight g5
And now it's very easy for black to blunder
I think a lot of players might think this is the move but it's not because the knight moves in
And simultaneously defends g5
Where should our knight go and this is a really pretty move?
Where should our knight drop down to?
So this is a really pretty move. Where should our knight drop down to?
Yeah back but where?
h7 is right knight h7 is the only good move
Because you want to add attackers to the g5 knight and if white plays h4 then you just take on g5
And obviously if f4 that's the other point you en passant him
White can keep putting pieces on the diagonal, but ultimately he's going to lose his queen
My opponent ended up giving up the full knight and I ended up winning the game. This was an 1800
So just keep these ideas in mind whichever Sicilian you play
I know not everybody who watches the speedrun is necessarily going to play my recommendations
But hopefully you can borrow at least some of the ideas to your own openings
All right
Back to the game. Well, there isn't too much to talk about truth be told
Once our opponent blunders now here white could have
White could have
Perhaps mitigated some of the damage by moving the bishop for example here
but this position still looks like garbage to me because
Just I don't think we need to talk about this for too much because f2 is hanging rook b8 is coming
If you can get white to play b3
Well, first of all here you can just take the pawn so you can analyze this a little bit on your own
Here the last chance for white to stay in the game was bishop e3
But I think this is borderline loss. I think this position is still losing
First of all, we hit the e3 pawn forcing another passive move
Now we go rook b8 and your goal is to induce b3 and I think a lot of players they might think well
What is the point of putting your pieces on the b file if white can just block it with b3?
Well, the point is that after b3 is played the knight has been softened up tremendously and you can now re
You could bring the bishop back to home base
Or and but I would first play a move like queen c5 to pressure the knight with the queen
And also the a3 square has been weakened tremendously. So it's a swiss cheese
Situation on the dark squares and the double whammy is that white lacks a dark squared bishop to defend these squares
So that's why in the long run white is completely busted here, even though it might not be totally obvious to you
immediately here
Queen d4 doesn't work. Just take it
Because the pawn is pinned. We're still on h6
Okay, if white plays king b1, I would drop the bishop back hit the knight
And once the knight is forced back, of course, you have the typical idea a5 a4
Or you could open up the center with d5 and bring this bishop out to f5 this position basically plays itself
classic right triangle so
This should be three would have been more resilient. Now. The game is not totally over
I would with white I think it's over after queen e2 here
There's just nothing left to talk about if I was playing white here
I think the last chance is to give up the bishop for a pawn
And then perhaps try a move like h3 to keep this knight confined the knight actually currently has no squares
But the move that I spotted here for black is queen to h4 we can eliminate the attacker
And I still think that it's completely winning and if white plays 92
Then our knight is able to evacuate via this new square which has opened up knight c4
The engine by the way recommends the move a g3 here
To solidify this pawn and now it gives d5
E takes d5
Slightly. Okay now just rook b8. So you open up the center by sacking a pawn and now you attack b2
And uh if king b1
Yeah, just cd knight d5 and just bishop b6 develop your pieces
Bishop g2 knight c4. Oh, yeah, this is just crushing
It's just crushing
Easy clap. Yeah. No white white is white is totally and completely lost. But after our opponent played queen e2
Uh, the one pitfall to avoid of course is not to take on f4 automatically
Understanding the concept of diminishing returns
Right, you shouldn't be rushing to take additional pawns here. The bishop is hanging black is still winning after bishop b5
You shouldn't panic if you blunder like this, and of course, you should keep your bishop at all costs
This position is still completely winning. Actually. It's plus four because you're up a pawn and you have a raging attack
but
Of course taking on d4
Obviates the need for that
And here queen b6 is I think very accurate
Here it took me a while
because
I wanted to to be as clinical as possible. I think queen c5 is fine. I'm sure the engine will have a more precise
Uh move in mind. It's giving d5 which is also good. The one thing to remember is that this is not forced mate
White can defend with king a1
And one thing i've seen some players forget about is in a situation like this a5 is not as good as it looks
Because once you play a4, it looks like you're winning but white can keep the situation clogged with b4
I can keep the situation clogged with b4
and rougue b8 is winning here, but it's a little bit cumbersome and suddenly things get a little bit sharper than they're supposed to
And by the way bishop back to g7 with the idea queen b2 check doesn't work
Because once the rook takes the king has that
Escape square on b1
So for that reason I wanted to keep the king stuck on c1
And that's why I played queen c5 threatening queen a3 forcing the rook away
And now you open up the center you play on all sides of the board
And I think the nicest win was bishop to g4. Yeah, it is the top move also because you keep the square
occupied
And while you keep it occupied you buy yourself a tempo to bring the rook to d8 to keep it occupied once again
So that's why not bishop f5 because here you're not covering the d1 square
Obviously, you're still completely winning but king d1 staves off the checkmate for a little bit longer
So bishop g4 rook d8 and our opponent resigned again bishop d3 the nicest win is rook takes d3
But for the context of the speed run, I would recommend that you just take with the pawn don't
You know look for adventures when there are none if you're up a piece and you're mating
Don't sacrifice unless you've calculated to checkmate and you're absolutely sure
That you know the sacrificial approach
leads to the desired result
so
that's about it folks and
That's about it folks. And again slightly underwhelming from a theory standpoint, but we're only 1800
You know, we're going until 22 2300. So i'm sure that we're going to get a lot of
More theoretically topical accelerated games as we go along
and
You know, that's the whole philosophy of this speed run the further along we get the more attention
I pay to mainstream theory the more time that we dedicate to
Specific theory as opposed to general concepts. This is only our second accelerated dragon game
So i'm still hitting on the kind of general ideas and hopefully you found this expose to be helpful
On that note folks, let's end wow four and a half hours. Can't believe it
This was a lot longer than anticipated. I have
Two hours to do a bunch of different things. So I gotta get to work. I will stream on thursday
I will stream on thursday. I also have pcl and then I probably will do a stream with botez
Thank you all, uh for the support
Every sub counts. My goal is to hit
400 000 subs by
By 20 by the start of 2024. It's a very modest goal, but
You know
We're moving along
100 subs at a time
Hopefully one day we can hit half a million. That would be a dream come true
You know every sub counts appreciate people's support
And youtube videos will be coming out at a normal pace
in the next few days
Have a great one and thanks for hanging out